put it all on the table put it all out  I'm tired  yep cardi B we'll be in the upcoming  fast nine in a mysterious new roles  taken noting that at first cardi joining  the car centric franchise seems like a  total match she and her husband offset  have a massive car collection  then he took [ __ ] trucks me back  Porsche rolls-royce truck my lambo damn  yo you see how gusty my Lambo is but  here's what's super ironic car D doesn't  know how to drive  you can't drive no so what's the point  of having new cars to take pictures baby  we don't know much about her fast 9 roll  but we're tempering our expectations a  little bit considering her much hyped  Hustler's appearance amounted to only a  few minutes of screen time we want more  car D  [Music]